[Applause]
[Music]
the icy cold of January is about to get
defrosted with a bunch of nostalgia this
week's new releases feature all sorts of
retro inspired games cutesy creatures
and a bit of anime let's get to it
Nintendo is taking another step into the
mobile gaming world with Fire Emblem
heroes the tactic series has been shrunk
down to run on your smartphone but the
rock paper scissor style combat is still
fully intact this time around you play
as a summoner who must save the kingdom
of Oscar from being conquered and to do
this you'll have to summon heroes from
all across the Fire Emblem universe that
means you'll be commanding characters
from last year's Fire Emblem fates all
the way back to the original NES release
Fire Emblem heroes comes to iOS and
Android on Thursday februari second
double dragon four is not the fourth
game in the series but that's not the
important part what you need to know is
that it picks up after Double Dragon 2
and sees billy and jimmy beating up a
bunch of new enemies maybe those street
thugs are just misunderstood in any case
you can totally play through the whole
thing with a friend beyond the story you
can fight your way through tower mode by
taking on waves of enemies or turn co-op
in the competition with the new duel
mode Double Dragon four blasts its way
onto ps4 on january twenty ninth and
onto pc on the 30th we have a review on
the way too so be sure to check back
later if you're not sure about picking
it up if you prefer to let monsters do
the fighting for you then you might be
into digimon world next order the latest
in the digital monsters series sees you
raising two digimon at once which means
twice the training and combat strategies
they can fight on their own or listen to
any commands you give during battle
which never seems to work with my cat
you can play as either a male or female
student and you'll run into over 200
digimon that can be recruited into
joining and expanding your village
digimon world next
order was released on the Vita in Japan
last year but it's coming stateside to
the ps4 on January 31st are you feeling
nostalgic for the good old fashioned
game boy warlocks tower has got you
covered but don't let the cutesy tile
set fool you this puzzle game is not
easy every step taken is one life lost
which means you have a limited number of
moves to get through over 100 rooms
they're filled with zombies slimes
conveyor belts blocks and all sorts of
things that just want to get in your way
luckily you can play tag team style with
a buddy so at least you'll get a
breather between puzzles warlocks tower
comes to pc on january thirty first
speaking of cutesy games Poochie &
Yoshi's woolly world is being shrunk
down for the 3ds the portable port has
everything from the Wii U game plus new
features like Poochie dash mode secret
Poochie pups and a scrapbook theater you
can still tap a Yoshi meebo to play as
double Yoshi in the game but the new
yarn pucci amoeba also adds new features
tap it in any main level and Yoshi will
ride his adorable dog tap it in one of
the bonus pucci stages to play in time
attack mode if you're in the mood for a
super cute platformer check out Poochie
& Yoshi's woolly world when it hits 3ds
on februari third and those are the big
games will be playing this week as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change and don't forget to
subscribe to keep up with all the
hottest new releases every week thanks
for watching guys I'll see you next time
you
[Music]